A read me file can technically
be written in any file format.
You can make your read me web page,
a simple text file or
even a made up format if you wanted to.
For this lesson,
you'll be generating your read me
using language known as markdown.
Markdown let's you generate
well formatted read mes
by translating them into HTML.
Sites that you may use often as
a developer, such as GitHub,
Stack Overflow, Slack, and even Reddit,
all use versions of markdown for
quick and
easy formating of your content.
One of the main advantages to using
markdown is that we can make read-mes
that are easy to skim through.
Take a look at these two recipes.
Both of these have the same information.
But without even needing to
read the contents of each,
which one would you rather follow?
The recipe on the right is
formatted in a way that makes it
easy to skim through.
When writing read-mes, take advantage of
the awesome features markdown gives you
to make sure they are easily readable.
You'll practice writing markdown
in the next few nodes, but
first I'll be giving you a quick
guide to markdown syntax.